Robert Pattinson is Batman with you oh
good yeah yeah why do you say he's
interesting
did you see the South Shore we'll come
up with something really interesting
yeah that's why you got some yeah man
that's right yeah he's really good
what's your advice to him slipping into
that suit Oh Sheamus for Ben just be
able to pee by yourself you don't feel
much like a superhero when you can't
take a piss hey everybody it's Charlie
so we finally found out what Christian
Bale thinks of all this Robert Pattinson
Batman news so we'll break it down we
also have a plot synopsis for the Batman
movie we'll do a new giveaway for the
Batman Beyond special editions they just
re-released it in HD it actually looks
amazing all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best new
Batman theory on the video there been a
couple rumors about the comic book
storylines they've been basing it on the
long Halloween in dark victory in that
haunted night because it's gonna be a
new Batman trilogy so we'll break that
down during the video but if you didn't
catch it Matt Damon actually references
a couple things obviously there's some
funny jokes about them putting a zipper
in the new version of the Batman suit
even though he's a champ Christian Bale
will always tell the story about how
infamously he made all three of those
Batman movies Batman Begins The Dark
Knight Dark Knight Rises through all the
different versions of his suit even
though they tuned them he only got a
couple suit changes but they would make
slightly different versions based on the
types of scenes they were filming and in
each case through all three of those
movies none of the suits actually had a
zipper that he was able to use to go to
the bathroom so just imagine him walking
around on set with a team of people
trailing him just to help him go to the
bathroom and he did that for three
separate movies no one thought to just
add a simple zipper to his suit I'm
assuming that because of the type of
story they're telling a neo noir
detective thriller Batman world's
greatest detective that he's going to be
way less armored than previous versions
of the character Ben Affleck and Batman
vs Superman
probably the most armored up we've seen
Batman in a live action movie even
Christian Bale were a pretty thick
version of the armor it makes sense if
the movie is not going to be quite as
big of an action film as previous Batman
movies before that his costume will be a
little bit more like the classic Batman
costumes I don't know exactly what the
color tones are going to be but
hopefully they go for some deep cuts
this is the funny story that Ben Affleck
tells about all the other previous
versions of Batman those actors giving
him advice when he was
first cast is Batman so did you reach
out to any of them you know I didn't
reach out to any of them I I have talked
to many of them since I had a really
interesting encounter I was buying my
kids one Tuesday afternoon we went to a
costume shop a Halloween shop there was
nobody in the place a woman proprietor
didn't recognize me or didn't care at
all was in there with my kids and I
heard this voice a boy like you
banging athle yeah I looked around
that's my British accent and I saw
Christian Bale the first thing I thought
was Christian Bale is British I really
was and and he was very friendly he was
buying he was there with his kid buying
Halloween costumes too and apparently
she didn't recognize him either
store costume shop and he was very
generous and kind his wonderful guy and
he said didn't make sure they put a
zipper in that suit I was it three
movies with no zipper in my outfit he
gave me some very practical advice I did
take that advice and as it turned for
yes and he was very very kind to me and
very sweet and I appreciate it because
it was it would have felt awful if I
thought you know that he was going
around you believe that I put in that
Batman and and I ended up running into
Michael Keaton and and I talked to
Clooney briefly whose advice was
unrepeatable and just a string of
epithets there clips from back around
Batman V Superman era when they were
promoting the movie that's why amy adams
is sitting there with them while they're
telling that story after listening to
that don't you want to know what Michael
Keaton and Val Kilmer told him about
being the Batman even Tom Holland on
spider-man homecoming said that Michael
Keaton gave him some great advice about
becoming this huge iconic comic book
character we were doing a scene that's
actually in the trailer and Michael
Keaton I've just punched Michael Keaton
in the face back and he's on the floor
and I'm standing over in on my
yeah but I'm spider-man and he looked up
at me and was like yeah well I'm Batman
but if you didn't catch it during the
clip at the beginning of the video when
Matt Damon references the saffron
Brothers movie that one Robert Pattinson
the Batman role they're talking about
good times if you haven't seen that
movie just brief plot synopsis is
basically the story about a bank robber
stopping at nothing to free his brother
from prison launching himself into a
night long Odyssey through New York's
dark and dangerous criminal underworld
about my brother I don't know exactly
what been arrested is a great movie but
the plot synopsis for that sounds eerily
similar to the plot synopsis for the new
Batman movie the plot synopsis for the
new Batman movie just reads there's a
string of murders that no one can solve
that takes them around to all the
different criminals that are gonna show
up during the film from the Batman
comics so you have the Riddler you have
the penguin two-face Mad Hatter is also
apparently supposed to be in the film
now so that's where you get your
detective story and does that not sound
like the plot of Batman the long
Halloween not exactly the same plot but
also a little bit like Batman mask of
the phantasm there's a mystery killer
nobody knows who it is Batman suspects
some of his biggest rogues so he goes
around investigating them finding out
that they're not the ones that are
really behind the murder if you've never
read the long Halloween just brief
explainer for what that story is just
careful for spoilers for the long
Halloween the plot of the movie will not
be exactly like the plot of the comic
book though during the story it's
relatively early in Batman's career he
does not know that Selina Kyle is the
Catwoman so he's dating Selina Kyle as
Bruce Wayne Selina Kyle also does not
know that Bruce Wayne is Batman Bruce
Wayne and Selina Kyle go to a party
thrown by carmine Falcone for his
nephews wedding in at that party carmine
Falcone tries to pressure Batman to help
launder money through one of his banks
with him Batman
turns him down they try to leave the
party but as they bolt they find Harvey
Dent has been roughed up this is before
he's become two-face so carmine Falcone
is putting pressure on Harvey Dent to
back off of the mob in his business
Batman forms a pact with Harvey Dent
before he becomes two-face in Detective
Gordon to take carmine Falcone down
without
stepping over the law eventually during
that story he winds up throwing the acid
on Harvey Dent's face after he becomes
District Attorney scarring him for life
that a bunch of mystery murders start
happening Batman goes around
investigating carmine Falcone finds that
he's not behind the murders all the
murders start happening after he becomes
two-faced though Batman suspects that
Harvey Dent two-face is revenge killing
all these mobsters in retribution for
what happened to him but then eventually
finds out that it's not Harvey Dent but
someone close to him then later you know
careful for spoilers for the end of the
long Halloween storyline you find out
that it was Harvey Dent's wife Gilda
that took retribution on the mobsters
for destroying her marriage with Harvey
Dent scarring him for life
two-face was so depressed that he felt
like nobody would ever be able to love
him even his own wife so his wife still
loved him but she was so angry what had
happened that that's why she ran around
committing all these murders even though
the plot of the movie is going to be
very different it's a situation like
that where Batman immediately suspects
that one of his leading villains is
probably behind a bunch of murders
secretly finds out that it's actually
someone else and winds up being a big
twist but it's so early in his career
he's still pretty young Batman that he
hasn't learned that Selina Kyle is
Catwoman so you also have the fun of him
chasing Catwoman around as Batman but
walking around with Selina Kyle in broad
daylight is Bruce Wayne with neither one
of them knowing each other secret
identity they slowly discover over the
course of that story
the animated Batman mask of the phantasm
movie fantastic also has a plot that's
relatively similar to the plot of Batman
the long Halloween with Batman
investigating this phantasm villain
that's going around killing all these
mobsters he doesn't understand the
motive he doesn't know why and it turns
out it's someone who was very near and
dear to him in his past that he almost
had a chance to get married to at one
point before he decided to become the
Batman your father's dead isn't he
you came into town early to get Chuckie
saw so you could shift the blame to your
father if you had to they took
everything Bruce my dad my life you I'm
not saying it's right or or even saying
but it's all I've got left so either
help me or get out of the way if you
haven't seen that movie be sure to go
watch it at some point is fantastic one
of the best Batman
movies of all time not just a really
good animated movie but also one of the
best Batman movies period I believe
they're shooting the movie early next
year so I think they're gonna announce
the Catwoman in their other major cast
before the end of the year so we'll find
out who's gonna be the new Selina Kyle
pretty quickly let me know in the
comments who do you want to be Robert
Pattinson 'he's Catwoman if they're
gonna be doing that romance during this
new trilogy of Batman movies I'll do
more Batman videos as we get more
details about the movie and find out
about more of the cast you're just
hearing a lot about it right now because
the studio is ramping up to start
production
everybody click here to watch Robert
Pattinson himself explained the Batman
movie and click here to learn about the
supposed new Wolverine versus Hulk movie
that's happening at Marvel thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]